welcome to this video yeah this would be
the first real game of this session I
actually have played two games before
against the same person but he was very
obvious cheater very a very negative way
to start a playing session okay now I'm
playing my way I did complain for
cheating but it doesn't help I have lost
two games against this this guy
okay now playing my way no region
opponent a very frequent opponent and
don't have a good score against some six
and a half out of 18 hmm not too great
and I normally have black I don't know
why but most of the time I have the
black pieces against him this time I had
white and he played the budapest gambit
slightly offbeat opening but it's one of
those openings that are really not
popular in top level chess but there are
not that bad though the budapest is the
the the real objection form for on top
level players is that it is slightly
passive opening very often it leads to a
pawn structure like this where black is
is just a little bit worse it's it's
nothing terribly serious but he is a
little bit worse okay I'm going to
prepare b3 look p b3 Bishop b2 and so on
Bishop f5 I have a four that's not a
problem yeah that's okay
be three immediately I wasn't sure if
Bishop f5 and might lead to trouble on
the long diagonal therefore this
preparation move yeah okay don't you get
this doing anyway okay so Bishop III
maybe Bishop III no impossible night
he's six no I will push this push this
immediately this is sound
probably ah I forgot about this reply
Brady that this is possible I didn't
think of hmm not so good
maybe 95 in this position gaining he
cannot play c6 and this is not badly
placed a five-year this is possible now
of course my takes fatigue Bishop takes
not good okay maybe I have to try to use
my my my rook here on D 1 was c5 getting
in Bishop Queen b3 check birth possible
or just take on d6
he's in a situation where he cannot take
on b5 as 96 is really I mean this is a
big weakness on d6 and if he takes on e4
I intended to take on d6 that's of
course a position that he excels and
he's a very good technical player a very
often outplay him strategically but he
is a really inventive
yeah that's a move that I probably
wouldn't even have considered but it's
maybe not bad um the take is six takes
this the chicken b3 and I win the Queen
so this should be really a good moment
to take on f5 also intense 96
what he managed to do in recent times he
plays much quicker than then earlier I
mean like two or three years ago I play
him for a while now and he always had a
huge time problems even a far more
serious than that then my tire problems
yeah okay but isn't this just good now
I mean 96 little threats he cannot
really take them I could have played 96
in any case know that I think of it yes
still 96 what is he doing then giving
the giving away the Queen or 96 I take
c7 and on another Queen move I take g7
just yeah um come on just getting this
is excellent bishop the bishop here on
g7 death is very very very important I
overlooked this move I can't play g3 how
about
g3 what exactly is this reply look f2r
what I don't understand anything here
okay I'm going to grab this grab this
piece and now we're taking on taking
here or take on see let's take here and
not spend more time texture the look and
it takes c6
just get rid of this this strong this
strong piece check here and we should be
three okay can also kick away click away
the knight Knight c3 bishop before a
bishop be - yeah just
ask him what he's doing with the 9000 in
a forum isn't this a deadly pin I mean
what exactly is going on here black
resigned as it is a deadly pin oh oh
it's a bit cautious because he's really
tricky so um such a good game you have
missing our sky I know it is a standard
message that he always sends it's
nothing that I must reply it necessarily
- yeah mm-hmm
I don't know if I've was was a very
aggressive move
that I have to have 96 now which I have
somehow didn't play I don't know why I
just should just play this and and do
take the rook it's it's even better than
what I did this is probably good for
white but it's not not not as clear of
course okay took them 96 Queen age 43
and takes yeah and I'm just much better
yeah so the way I played wasn't totally
totally bad but the other thing was was
better I here look before I could move
just attacking the knight but this this
shouldn't be bad right
just this should keep a big edge I hope
yeah it's essentially winning as well
it's not so convincing but it's enough
to win yeah I guess this was just too
much this f5 move if he plays some
if we go back here if he plays something
normal instead it should be should be
quite okay for like I mean I have more
space so I should be a little bit better
but it's nothing dramatic I think okay I
hope you enjoyed this game thanks for
watching